[Aplausos]
[Música]
vladimir putin es nuestro chuck norris
particular en visual polític le hemos
dedicado decenas de vídeos y vosotros
nuestros queridos suscriptores siempre
nos pedís más así que hoy vamos a hablar
del videojuego favorito de putin
ucrania es como el paris hilton de los
países solo hablamos de ellos cuando ha
ocurrido algo realmente malo y lo cierto
es que en este país llevan tres años sin
tener una buena noticia durante el año
2016 parecía que estos dos bandos que se
han visto enfrentados en una encarnizada
guerra el pro ruso y el pro ucr han ya
no iban a llegar a un acuerdo sin
embargo en febrero de 2017 ha ocurrido
algo que ha vuelto a colocar a ucrania
en el punto de mira de la noticia
acepta los pasaportes emitidos por los
rebeldes ucranianos ojo porque esto es
muy importante hasta ahora vladimir
putin negaba en público estar apoyando
al bando pro ruso
de hecho la comunicación oficial del
kremlin siempre se ha referido a estos
grupos como los separatistas rebeldes
por supuesto que todas las evidencias
apuntaban a que putin estaba ayudando
con armamento y apoyo militar a las
facciones rebeldes de la misma forma que
la otan estaba haciendo lo mismo con el
ejército ucraniano
[Música]
pero la versión oficial del gobierno
ruso es que ellos no tenían nada que ver
con el tema sin embargo esta noticia
marca un antes y un después a partir de
ahora rusia reconoce de facto como
estados soberanos a las repúblicas
populares del dones y de luhansk y os
preguntaréis y todo esto qué
consecuencias tiene pues varias por un
lado se están posicionando clara e
institucionalmente por uno de los bandos
del conflicto
pero por el otro lado putin está
reconociendo que estas dos repúblicas no
son parte de rusia es decir hasta ahora
todos pensábamos que putin quería
invadir ucrania y anexionar lo como una
parte más de rusia pero de verdad esto
es así hoy vamos a responder a esta
pregunta y lo vamos a hacer de la mano
del que fue corresponsal de guerra en
ucrania para televisa y la televisión
checa carlos gonzález no sólo eso además
carlos es uno de los pocos periodistas
que ha llegado a estar capturado por un
escuadrón del ejército pro rusos
todas esas imágenes nunca vistas hasta
ahora van a salir a la luz en un
documental titulado ucrania la guerra
olvidada o la fonseca y un abrazo a
todos los suscriptores de visual
político efectivamente como dice ese
footing tiene intereses sobre ucrania
aunque resulta un poco aventurado pensar
en este momento que quiera anexarse el
país o parte de él hay malas razones
para pensar esto pero en primer lugar yo
pienso que tú tienes jamás tuvo
intereses serios de anexarse digamos la
zona del tumbas o alguna otra zona
rusoparlante de ucrania sino porque
había enviado tremendas cantidades de
armamento ayuda logística misiones a un
país que finalmente terminaría tan
dañado
pero esperad un momento porque antes
vamos a ver un poco de historia
la revolución del euro mine and a
diferencia de otras repúblicas
exsoviéticas como bielorrusia donde la
mayor parte de la población se siente
muy cercana a rusia la historia de
ucrania es muy distinta y la podemos
resumir como una tensión entre dos
partes muy diferenciadas
en este mapa electoral podéis ver esta
franja azul en la parte oeste del país
estos son los su cara no parlantes que
mayoritariamente votan a partidos
políticos más o menos liberales y pro
europeístas sin embargo la otra mitad
como podéis ver es completamente roja en
estas áreas es donde se vota
mayoritariamente al partido de las
regiones que es el partido político en
el que se afiliaron todos los antiguos
gerifaltes del partido comunista
soviético entre ellos este señor que
veis aquí que se llama víctor yanukóvich
quedaros con este nombre porque es uno
de los protagonistas de esta historia
durante los años 90 estas élites post
soviéticas tenían el poder sin embargo
en el año 2003 las tornas se cambiaron
hablamos de la llamada 'revolución
naranja' donde todos los sectores pro
occidentales encabezados por yulia
timoshenko y víctor yúschenko se
hicieron con el gobierno
[Música]
sin embargo este nuevo gobierno no
supuso ningún cambio sustancial para el
país no se aplicaron reformas
importantes es más ni siquiera fueron
capaces de desmantelar la policía
política represiva de yanukóvich como
resultado en el año 2010 el partido de
las regiones se convirtió en la
principal fuerza política volvieron a
ganar las elecciones y el propio
yanukóvich se convirtió en 2010 en el
presidente del país y por supuesto una
de sus primeras medidas fue meter en la
cárcel a yulia timoshenko en este
segundo gobierno de yanukóvich los
ucranianos sobre todo aquellos que no le
votaron sufrieron en sus propias carnes
la corrupción la desigualdad económica y
la brutalidad policial sin embargo en
noviembre de 2013 estalló una nueva
revolución y ésta sí que estaba llamada
a cambiar la historia de ucrania para
siempre el gobierno de yanukóvich estaba
a punto de firmar un tratado de
asociación por la unión europea algo que
era apoyado por muchos ucranianos
principalmente en occidente donde son
más pro europeos y además se habían
hecho muchas esperanzas porque se
trataba de colocar a ucrania
un pasito más cerca de las estructuras
euroatlánticas es decir formar parte de
la otan y formar parte de la unión
europea
sin embargo en el último momento
yanukóvich cedió a las presiones de
putin y se negó a firmarlo
así es como surgieron las famosas
protestas del euro my dad
soy ucraniana de kiev y ahora estoy en
maidán en el centro de mi ciudad
uruguay quiero que sepáis por qué miles
de personas de todo el país están en las
calles
más de 100 personas murieron en los
enfrentamientos que hubo entre la
policía y los manifestantes en unas
protestas que se alargaron durante meses
así que al final a viktor yanúkovich no
le quedó otra alternativa que esto
me vi obligado a dejar ucrania bajo una
amenaza a mi vida y a la vida de mi
familia y así es como ucrania comenzó
una segunda transición esta vez sin la
influencia de las élites herederas de la
unión soviética
y el mayor símbolo de esta nueva
revolución ucraniana fue la liberación
de yulia timoshenko pero no sólo eso
muchos de estos grupos que lograron de
poner a víctor yanukóvich se llegaron a
plantear prohibir el ruso en todo el
país pero por otro lado esta es a
ucrania rusoparlante esa importante
mayoría que todavía incluso apoya en
cierta manera casi nostálgica de las
antiguas élites por eso como sucedió en
crimea en algunas regiones del país
principalmente en el donbass no estaban
tan de acuerdo con lo que estaba
sucediendo en tierra
[Música]
[Aplausos]
estaban de acuerdo con que se llevara a
cabo una transición según numerosos
censo casi el 80% de la población de
crimea se declararon su parlante y no
siente gran pertenencia a ucrania por
eso cuando se empiezan a producir los
movimientos separatistas en ucrania por
allá por 2014
entonces crimea es uno de los primeros
en llamar a un referéndum de
autodeterminación
[Música]
a muchos os sonará porque solía ser una
zona de vacaciones de hecho era una
especie de ibiza ucraniana muchos
europeos volaban hasta sinferópol para
pasar un fin de semana de fiesta no
olvidéis que crimea está en el mar negro
se trata de una zona muy importante
desde el punto de vista militar y que
además tiene yacimientos de petróleo es
decir todas aquellas cosas que hacen que
un lugar sea atractivo para la invasión
[Aplausos]
así que desde el primer momento vladimir
putin se colocó en el lado de los
separatistas y antes de que el ejército
de ucrania pudiera hacer nada ya estaban
las tropas rusas ocupando el lugar mucho
mejor equipadas con muchos más soldados
y sobre todo con mucho más apoyo de la
población local así que ni siquiera hizo
falta una guerra los rusos llegaron
dijeron esto es mío y punto final
sin embargo no ocurrió lo mismo en estas
otras dos zonas que veis en el mapa
donde se alojan estas dos regiones
forman parte de lo que se conoce como el
donbass que es la zona más prorrusa de
toda ucrania sin embargo no tienen
ningún recurso natural ni ningún interés
estratégico de ningún tipo
declaro la creación del estado
independiente y soberano de la república
popular de dones
[Aplausos]
y así fue con la declaración de
independencia de las repúblicas
populares de dones y luján como empezó
[Música]
el conflicto armado de ucrania en ningún
momento rusia apoyó oficialmente la
independencia de estas dos regiones y
esto qué significa os preguntaréis pues
que aunque les mandaran asesoramiento
militar armamento y material de todo
tipo no les mandaron tropas a diferencia
de lo que hicieron en crimea y esto
sirvió para que el ejército ucraniano se
atreviera a hacer frente a los
separatistas
una de las batallas más importantes
diría yo de toda la guerra en ucrania
una de las batallas
casi épicas fue la batalla por el
aeropuerto de gómez
[Música]
nosotros cubriendo la zona aledaña al
aeropuerto zona según nosotros civil
somos capturados por un batallón de
milicianos pro rusos acusado de estar
espiando para una potencia occidental
allá que nos encontramos en mi zona
celebra su campeonato
el momento en que capturan nosotros
decidimos dejar la cámara prendida para
poder tratar de grabar parte de ese
momento tan dramático la dejamos
prendida incluso durante el periodo en
que son los trasladados al cuartel
general de las milicias rebeldes y parte
del interrogatorio que se desarrolla
después en medio de mente de milicianos
armados hasta los dientes que nos
seguían acusando de estar trabajando
digamos de forma ilegal y de haber
estado espiando para intereses
extranjeros
[Música]
no olvidéis que la otan también estaba
apoyando al otro bando especialmente el
gobierno de canadá que ha estado
mandando a soldados asesores militares y
armamento de todo tipo de milicias
rebeldes de la autoproclamada república
popular de donges que acusan a kiev de
ser bombardeada sus posiciones por
artillería pesada
y esta es una muestra de lo que estamos
hablando en este momento estos son
esquirlas de misiles de artillería
pesada
[Música]
estamos ya en febrero de 2015 la
situación es de auténtica guerra civil
con más de 5000 muertos en ambos lados
del conflicto tanto dones como luján son
auténticos campos de batalla y por
supuesto el gobierno de ucrania no tiene
ningún poder en estas zonas controladas
por los rebeldes
eso significa que ni las escuelas ni los
hospitales ni ningún edificio
administrativo puede funcionar
correctamente y lo más importante los
ciudadanos comunes tienen que sobrevivir
en casas destartaladas y derruidas por
los bombazos
[Música]
e
i
en ese momento es cuando representantes
por un lado del gobierno de ucrania y
por otro lado de los supuestos gobiernos
de esta república recientemente
declaradas se reúnen en miles para
acordar un alto el fuego sin embargo el
cese al fuego jamás se ha respetado la
violencia continua no solamente entre
los dos bandos beligerantes sino también
las violaciones contra la población
civil son cada vez más evidentes
no sabemos exactamente qué es lo que fue
de acuerdo al estado caminando por una
aldea que fuera probablemente una de las
más castigadas durante la guerra la
aldea de inquilino a unos 800 kilómetros
de kiev la capital de ucrania cuando en
la calle el colegio público al interior
del colegio público local nos
encontramos una mina antipersona sin
estallar
bueno
es algo brutal se trata de la cabeza de
una mina no lo voy a hacer porque esta
mina todavía está
funcionando lo que sucede cuando no
aprieta este botón es que activa el
mecanismo que hace detonar la mina
el edificio lo colocó arriba y apretó el
botón en este momento podría
efectivamente explotar horas después
escuchamos dos explosiones de minas
similares a ésta se estima que cerca de
1.000 personas han perdido la vida por
explosiones de minas similares a estas
en operarios
adquiere putin invadir ucrania a día de
hoy el este de ucrania es un lugar sin
gobierno tanto luhansk como dones son
zonas controladas por señores de la
guerra que luchan entre ellos con la
misma fiereza con la que luchan contra
el ejército de ucrania y en contra de lo
que podríamos pensar no hay ningún líder
claramente apoyado por vladimir putin
muchas ciudades del donbass como por
ejemplo 10 como de valls evo la propia
nick y si no de la que hablábamos hace
un momento han sido literalmente
arrasadas por la guerra más de un millón
de personas estima que han tenido que
escapar a otras partes del país incluso
las universidades se han visto forzadas
a cerrar sus puertas
es decir si rusia realmente quisiera
anexarse estos territorios tendría que
desembolsar importantes cantidades de
presupuesto para poder reconstruir la
infraestructura reconstruir carreteras
hospitales
la economía rusa en este momento no pasa
precisamente por su mejor momento las
sanciones impuestas por eeuu la unión
europea a rusia a raíz de crimea han
tenido un impacto bastante notorio en
las finanzas del país y pareciera que
putin no quiere volver a repetir esto
mismo más aún tratándose de territorios
que ofrecen una perspectiva geopolítica
tan pero tan difusa
[Música]
no sólo eso muchos pensaréis que a
vladimir putin de alguna forma está
apoyando a los líderes pro rusos verdad
pues os equivocáis
[Música]
un señor de la guerra separatista arséne
y motorola pavlov muere en dones muchos
piensan que este asesinato podría ser
una muestra de la guerra territorial
entre diferentes facciones rebeldes en
el este de ucrania posiblemente
incluyendo a algún gerifalte de moscú
[Música]
y ahora os preguntaréis si putin no
quiere invadir ucrania qué intereses
tiene en este conflicto es decir que
espera obtener de esta guerra todo esto
se explica con la famosa teoría de las
siete fases que define la política
exterior del kremlin si queréis entender
bien en qué consiste este principio
hacer clic en este vídeo
[Música]
y ahora la pregunta es creéis que
ucrania debería separarse en dos países
distintos uno pro europeo y otro pro
ruso podéis dejarme la respuesta en los
comentarios pero esperad un momento
porque tengo algo importante que
contaros si queréis ayudar a difundir lo
que está ocurriendo en ucrania ahora
tenéis una oportunidad este documental
del que hoy os hemos puesto algunas
piezas está a punto de proyectarse en
los principales festivales del mundo
pero antes falta un pequeño empujón en
la producción
mi amigo carlos está buscando apoyo a
través de una plataforma de crowdfunding
que se llama indiegogo así es un seca
gracias a decenas de personas que han
creído en esta iniciativa es que hemos
alcanzado dos terceras partes de los
fondos necesarios para poder realizar
este proyecto pero ahora necesitamos
darle un empujoncito más y es ahí donde
tu audiencia nos puede apoyar
tremendamente amigos de visual política
por favor si pueden apoyarnos aunque sea
un dólar un modesto dólar puede marcar
una gran diferencia para poder ayudarnos
a alcanzar esta meta sino por lo menos
darnos like en nuestra página de
facebook comparte nuestra iniciativa en
las redes sociales eso también nos
ayudará tremendamente podéis encontrar
todos los links en la descripción y de
verdad que es un proyecto que merece la
pena carlos es amigo mío desde hace años
antes vivía en praga y es uno de los
pocos periodistas que ha estado a ambos
lados del conflicto ucraniano y os puedo
asegurar que muchas de las imágenes que
se van a ver en este documental son
únicas y no se han visto nunca antes así
que si queréis apoyar a nuevos creadores
esta es una oportunidad muy
y como siempre recordad que sacamos
vídeos nuevos todas las semanas así que
suscribirse al canal para no perderos
ninguna de nuestras actualizaciones si
os ha gustado este vídeo dadle a like y
nos vemos en el próximo un abrazo y
hasta pronto
[Música]
[Aplausos]